tell me do you feel like women typically
understand the consequences for their
choices or do you feel like it's a
surprise later this is a surprise later
100 Surprise later 100 is a surprise
what do you guys think yeah it's a
surprise yeah I think we
um choose choose more on just our
initial
emotions oh yeah yeah
I agree yeah I think some don't care as
well
that's crazy though like you all
understand
that is a surprise later you all still
make choices that if the dot doesn't
consider Yeah because sometimes you
don't think things through so yeah
women or I don't know some women don't
think things through this impulse and
they go for it where sometimes you could
be a bag of emotions like our hormones
got up and down all the time so
sometimes that could be great because I
can't be great and I can't necessarily
always balance that but then this is why
you self-reflect and you learn you're
the incognizant of those emotions and
then you understand that when you feel
that way you stop and think I mentioned
it instead of acting no but you don't
know much that's what you said earlier
men do tend to be more logical whilst
women tend to be more it's easier for us
to say that when we don't go through
something every once a month like it's
easier for us to say it when we've never
had to do it I'm not trying to see yeah
it is easier I'm just saying that for me
personally yeah when I saw reflects when
I try to teach myself growth to
understand myself better yeah when I
feel a certain way I stop so when I was
younger I used to get into a lot of
facts I was very angry person I would
smack people up but then when I started
when I start to understand the
repercussions of my actions the way it
could land me when I get angry how young
was that you taught you how to do that
my parents and how are you know myself
then I I carry on
um going through that myself well we're
chemically we are chemically different
every single day yeah I don't but I
don't think that's an excuse for poor
Behavior no no just because we didn't
think something through like why why
should the men have to deal with that
but then that's like saying how um sorry
like men are prone to be more like
aggressive and stuff like that people
say that but then is that an excuse for
them to if they ever feel you know what
I mean like it goes both ways yeah but I
think the difference is when when women
have a standard we're praised for it and
when men have a standard they're shamed
for for example
um fat phobic okay
um [ __ ] shaming those are those are all
to take away the consequence for women's
bad decisions
um okay so where whereas a woman if a
woman says oh I want to keep my
standards High I should never settle the
girls Gasser up everyone gasses her up
wait are you off the girls the question
like so if if is it okay to ask your
guys he's hired no I feel silly what'd
you go think
do you think it's okay no I don't think
it's silly to us but I don't think it's
needed
so like a guy you've never seen before
you find them attractive is it okay to
ask him he's like absolutely yeah if
you're like a more taller girl you need
to know it okay the man is tall because
some people don't know so reverse um is
it okay for Matt to ask a girl about her
weight on a day yet
if you want I mean if if you want if
that's you know you can I don't live in
the hype theme because
because that's the question first of all
is it okay I might have asked me on
hinge before how fat how how big are you
okay what about girls what do you think
if you asked me and I sent you a text
saying okay yeah I'm eight stone you're
gonna think oh I know exactly what that
looks like
I could be eight stone and five foot
eleven I'm not asking whoever it's like
whoever you think it's okay because wait
no hi yeah which is and that's and
that's yeah and that's to the point to
be fair the weight is within your
control whilst your height is something
you can't control so wouldn't it make
more sense to be okay to ask about
something like wait in in compared to
hey I hear what you're saying but that's
why hinge is great because a guy has to
put his height on there anyway so you
don't need to ask if you haven't got it
on there then it's for a reason but
these are some of the double standards
that where women are praised or certain
things or men have to they have to face
the reality straight on yeah and it's
the same thing with only fans like if a
man has no skills and no job he's
homeless a girl can make six figures in
a month just starting an only fans if
she was born attractive
but I say if she's born attractive if
you're not born attractive then you're
going to be homeless
now you've been paid to be attractive so
sorry Trisha penis makes a lot of money
on only fans I do not think she's
attractive I don't think you need to be
attractive if you've got big back and
big boobs yeah
funny enough the highest paid like
people in sex work are people that look
young that that look like kids yes
because men want that a lot of men want
that though they're attracted to
fertility
if you survey men between the age most
women peek at like 22 at 21. some some
even earlier because if you survey men
from 20 to 80 and you ask them what age
do you find women the most attractive
they'll say 22 23. I think even on
Netflix they did a blind small test both
for women and men women tend to be more
attracted to men with high levels of
testosterone whilst men were attracted
to younger women and that's based on
smell so I was shared High um so women
so so they got meant to sweat they got
meant to sweat and then you based on
smell who were the most attractive to
without being able to see the guys and
it was attracted to guys with higher
testosterone when they did the same for
men to women
um when were attracted to women who were
younger but what was because they were
younger because what was it that made
them attractive as well it's fertility
so men are biologically predispositioned
to want to spread their seed
like what do you know what the Genghis
Khan stat is where like it's like one
out of every 100 or one out of every 50
people in China related to Genghis
Khan's he was just slaying so many hoes
like I had so many concubines yeah we
have different reproductive strategies
like a man's reproductive strategy
scatter gun spread your seat to as many
people as you want a woman whilst
woman's is to to bag the best they can
get and hold on to it because that's
what that's what ensures safety and
that's when you see to make more people
you're spreading USD to make more to
spread your
Genesis
to make your genes your your specific
genes I know so that means you're gonna
make a baby right okay but you're just
spelling it you just out here with no
condom just scattering around there we
are biologically predisposed to do that
that's what we're born to do can I just
scroll back to something real quick
sorry
um just where you guys were talking
about your number with a girl would be
ten would is that like lower than what
you would go to Just where we were
talking about double standards I just
want to check that real quick yeah so
you're like you wouldn't sleep with more
than 10 girls that's your cat yeah I
would have wanted yeah I'm asking you
both at 28.
you wouldn't you didn't you wouldn't
wear to go that set with more than 10
guys just you know where you're talking
about double standards before so I just
I was just checking like I was just I
think she wants to know your number bro
what's your cat when do you say no I've
had I've had way too much sex I'm gonna
stop now and settle down listen yeah we
play about different rules with it
I'll I'll I'll land on that so we
obviously as many women we play by
different standards here so when I say
men or men women are born a value whilst
men have to create their value yeah so
for a woman acquiring sex is as simple
as walking out that street you're going
to get sex right now yeah so you can
have zero value like um tangible value
and just being born a woman means you're
guaranteed a seat at a table when it
comes to the sexual Marketplace as a man
before you're granted the opportunity to
have sex you have to become something
you have to be worth something so how
can you then place the same value on sex
for men as women and that's the only
double standard that doesn't benefit
women and and it's really not that crazy
to just not sleep
with the provider role
so we're okay with that double standard
because honestly if you're okay with
that double standard why isn't it not
okay for a woman to want someone a bit
bigger and want that provider then
because maybe she doesn't find a
provider in someone that is okay yeah
but then it doesn't mean she's any less
lovable if she's a certain weight does
it not whereas like if it's something at
least for like a lot of girls like
taller girls they just like the taller
men because it gives them a sense of
comfort
girl is that making you all women want
tall men that's not true
okay what does a woman of a certain
weight give you whereas like a man of a
certain height men they're attracted to
to think physical yeah hips naturally
isn't it genetic like The Wider the hips
it's more yes yes so that's that's why
women but that's why women are sorry not
women that's why men are attracted to
the hourglass figure right the wide hips
but yeah that's not that doesn't mean
rolls that just means wide hips yeah and
and men can't help that they're not
attracted to bigger women in general
that's why you see the most attractive
or the most powerful
men
end up with models yeah have it as money
not because of anything else well no I'm
saying we're taking the people the two
people with the most options oh okay
yeah are they they typically are thinner
women and rich men yeah then a lot of
models are just slim and slender they
don't really have the hips to have what
you yeah do you know I mean whereas you
can get not always but a lot of curvy
girls Secrets they are they look good I
don't know they do but they're very slim
and slender I I don't think men are
looking at least I don't think you guys
are looking at Victoria's Secret models
being like Oh yeah that's going to be
perfect for myself you don't know what
again I'm praying but no yeah
I mean guys have different types that's
true some guys prefer you know more of
the Instagram Baddie where it's The
Hourglass and some guys prefer more of
just the skinny slender yeah that's true
but at the end of the day it's still
we're talking about in general men
prefer thinner women yeah yeah
but remember that not everyone has the
same
um
basically everyone has different options
and what the what they prefer and so
when we're shouting out these stats or
whatever let's let's be
um rather objective about it and say
that it's some not all because you know
I know men personally that that prefer
um a woman who's bigger than them yeah I
know
um
I know men who are shorter but they want
a really tall woman yeah yeah I think
that's what oh no guys they love the top
they do yeah
we don't we don't love them like it's
not
but but but the thing is we're talking
about in general like if we talk if we
talk if we spent this podcast talking
about the exceptions we'd be here all
day we didn't get nowhere yeah there
would be no point in having a
conversation I still need to mention
them why there's no questions
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible